in this morning's eye on earth we take a
closer look at how climate change and
droughts have affected one of this
country's most important crops the US is
one of the world's leading cotton
exporters with an industry estimated to
generate more than 21 billion dollars of
products and services a year we've been
following this story since last fall
when we visited a cotton farm during
harvest season and we went to a lab
where they've developed new ways to
reduce environmental stress when you
think of cotton you likely picture the
white fluffy cloud like so-called fabric
of our lives but here in Boston cotton
is growing in labs virtually every major
crop in the US and around the world is a
significant risk to climate change and
cotton is no exception to that as the
earth gets warmer with climate change
scientists have been looking to combat
increasing environmental stresses on
crops with innovation Jeffrey Van
Moulton and his team at a startup called
indigo say they've developed a
breakthrough drought resistant seed
water stress and and drought in cotton
is the most important stress in
agriculture that it has almost no
solutions today remarkably Nature has
found a whole bunch of solutions to that
in the microbiome think of a microbiome
as a plant's gut filled with tiny
microbes they discovered which ones from
within a cotton plant deal with water
stress they then coat the seeds with
those specific microbes to make them
more resilient in dry conditions it's
allowed us to grow cotton that is better
able to withstand the stress that plant
experiences with a given amount of water
restriction they say their methodology
is more natural than genetically
modified mass-produced seeds the plants
are exposed to scorching temperatures in
grow rooms then they're tested in the
hot fields outside cotton is trying to
survive many farmers have abandoned the
crop because of low profits and those
challenging conditions more than a
century and a half ago
cotton dominated agriculture in the
American South first picked by
generations of slaves and then
sharecroppers modern-day cotton farming
continues in states like Texas but dry
and hot weather has pushed farmers to
get creative we were looking for any way
to
find an edge in Lubbock Texas Stetson
Hogue and his family have been growing
cotton for generations they were one of
the few cotton farms to survive a
four-year drought that started in 2011
we've definitely lost a few growers in
the last few years and I would say that
that certainly has more to do with kind
of the whole economics of farming thank
you the kind of the farming environment
that we're dealing with some people say
that the weather is changing that
climate change is creating drier
conditions which is making it harder to
grow cotton has that been your
experience you know I couldn't say that
we are kind of used to drought here you
know it's just something that we've
always had to deal with like many
farmers hope believes that droughts he's
experienced are part of normal weather
trends not the result of climate change
still he wants seeds that can perform
better in dry conditions to provide a
much needed lift to profits my granddad
30 to 40 years ago could buy a new
tractor for $20,000 a new tractor today
cost $200,000 okay so we're selling our
cotton today for 70 to 75 cents
he sold his cotton for 70 to 75 cents so
obviously there's a there's a big gap
there and it's just it's been a real
challenge but for many cotton farms this
innovation came too late over the last
few years some cotton growers in this
area have shut down completely
others have diversified into other crops
that can better survive these dry
conditions like grapes this land has
been cotton historically for the last 60
years 100 percent of it and we changed
our minds and decided to take a chance
with a vineyard here in 2015 with her
cotton yields declining Katy Jane Seaton
poured her efforts into winemaking
since grapes are more resistant to
drought there's much more vitality in
grapes if you can keep them alive you
are not the hold into the marketplace
that marketplace is sure to keep
changing as the earth gets hotter which
means more demand for seeds that can
thrive in our warmer world you may be
wondering how the higher cost of
producing cotton will impact US
consumers the farmers say it won't while
the cost of producing cotton keeps
increasing there
the ones who bear the brunt of it I
don't know how long that can last at
some point customers are gonna have to
start paying more - I'm really curious
about this there's a so there's a new
effort to create a more resistant
drought resistant crop to address
climate change what do these farmers
even believe in climate change
it seems skeptical he is skeptical he
says that the drought that they
experienced that was devastating to
their business is just part of normal
weather trends we hear that a lot on
bass in the Midwest we interview a lot
of farmers they don't believe in global
warming a lot of them not everyone but a
lot of them believe that these are just
normal weather patterns that their
parents and grandparents have had to
deal with but what's also interesting is
how the tariff war with China is
affecting cotton prices it's creating
volatility in the cotton market and
Chinese importers have to pay tariffs on
imported cotton u.s. us importers of
cotton fabric are now under threat of
having to pay tariffs on cotton that's
coming back in the form of fabric that's
a piece of cotton shirts does he seem
worried to you he doesn't he says that
what he's doing is he's investing in
these drought resistant seeds because he
needs a bit he needs to make more
profits because it's costing hundreds of
thousands of dollars for these combines
but the cotton is still being sold at
the same prices as will need to pay
everyone the kind of fast fashion $2.00
shirts throw it out that people need to
pay a little more they really do support
your farmers support your farmers indeed